What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And welcome to another episode of Challenge
Pongfinity
This is the series where YOU
challenge US
With your craziest ideas
related to table tennis.
If your idea gets picked
We will give you a shout out
And feature in our next video.
So make sure you leave your comments and ideas
In the comment-section below!
Antion Diachuk is wondering if it's possible
To serve around the net.
Let's find out.
Since it wasn't possible to do it with a normal
table
We did have to add some length.
Rohan Poddar wants me to play with a shuttle
cock
instead of a racket.
I think Miikka will have no chance against
me!
Raja Rapn wants us to do smashes on 2 tables.
Vijay Singhal wants to see us play with a
cloth hangar.
Thanks for watching!
If you enjoyed this episode make sure to leave
it a thumbs up!
And if you are new to the channel subscribe
here!
And watch our other videos here.
Until next time!